well thank you much very much for the
honor of being here
tonight um I'm going to give you a
little bit of a disclaimer up front it's
like one of those warning
labels in the Central Intelligence
Agency all the record communication is
carried out in written form I mean they
got radios and television and I mean
telephones and stuff right but but they
send what they still call cables back
and forth and that's how you communicate
officially and there's this unofficial
expression called
CES which is the way you write so it's
this very stilted overly polite form of
writing think about some Englishmen in a
stuffy British club in the late 1800s
where everything is understated and
indirect and nobody raises their voice
so the disclaimer is this I was never
any good at
that so some somewhere in the bowels of
headquarters are hundreds of messages
back to me in the field beginning with
an statement to the effect of thank you
for your
cander you will understand in kiz that's
not what that means that means you're a
rude SOB aren't you
Fus but my intention is not to be rude
and I don't think I'll be rude to any of
you but I think we're talking about some
very important
matters and the hour is late
and the risk is very real the danger is
grave and so if there was a time to pull
punches and dance around issues it has
long
passed so what I want to talk to you
about
is the Central Intelligence Agency what
has gone wrong and what we need to do to
fix it I will begin with this additional
statement I wrote a book a number of
years ago about the CIA called Beyond
repair talking about what had happened
to it and I began with a disclaimer that
said nothing in the book should be
interpreted as an attack on the men and
women in the Central Intelligence Agency
in the field doing the
job right everybody in Washington these
days as far as I can tell talks in terms
of being on the front lines of Defending
democracy I'm not sure I even know
exactly what that's supposed to mean in
some cases what I do know is
this the men and women of the CIA are
way out in front of those front lines
deep in enemy territory every day they
do not do it for the pay and they sure
as heck don't do it for the
recognition they do it because they know
as I know and I suspect everybody in
this room knows that there really are
monsters out there
and somebody needs to be protecting us
from
them we need the
CIA but we also need to recognize an
uncomfortable
reality the CIA is not performing at the
level we require it is not keeping us
safe it must be repaired and it must be
repaired quickly and let me illustrate
what I'm talking about to take this from
the abstract to the concrete with a few
examples the CIA was created after World
War
II with one overriding primary missions
this is why we built the thing to
prevent a reoccurrence of what happened
on December 7th
1941 we were never going to allow an
enemy to surprise us on that scale ever
again again we were never going to find
ourselves blind regarding a threat of
that magnitude and
immediacy before anything else this was
be the job of the Central Intelligence
Agency it was to prevent another
surprise
attack then came September 11th
2001 members of al-Qaeda hijacked four
airliners they crashed three of them
into their intended
targets the fourth was prevented from
reaching its Target only by the heroism
of The Americans on
board Al kaido was not some unknown
entity that materialized out of nowhere
it had been around for years about every
five minutes Bin Laden had been telling
us it was his intention to attack us
here to attack what he called the far
enemy they had already blown up two of
our embassies in East Africa
they had almost sunk the USS coal in
Yemen they had already tried once before
to take down the World Trade
Center and yet we had not a single
Source inside
Al-Qaeda capable of warning us of the
attack that would ultimately kill
roughly 3,000
Americans May 2nd 2011 US Special
Operations per Personnel attacked a
compound in
Pakistan and killed The Mastermind in
the 911 attacks Osama Bin
Laden that operation in and of itself
clearly a
success the fact that it took us almost
years after 911 to find and kill Bin
Laden is what should give us
pause Bin Laden understood the technical
capabilities of American intelligence
after his escape from Afghanistan he
established himself in a compound with
no internet service he had no cell phone
he communicated with his organization
via a courier system and dealt with
those couriers face to face there were
no emails text messages or phone calls
for us to
intercept that boils down to this
finding Bin Laden meant getting a source
inside Al-Qaeda at a high enough level
to know his physical
location it took almost a full
decade for CIA with all of its resources
to acquire such a
source despite the fact that locating
Bin
Laden was bar nothing else the single
top priority for the agency for that
entire decade collection Target number
one one 10
years
Co bring this a little more recent in
20120 we found ourselves in the midst of
the so-called worldwide
pandemic which originated in
China despite attempts to characterize
this as a natural
outbreak that could be the
FBI
it's it's it sounds like them and it's
consistent with their tradecraft
so we find ourselves in the middle of
this pandemic and despite all this
nonsense about this being a natural
outbreak it has become abundantly clear
that coid 19 came out of a lab in Wuhan
China was the product of gain of
function research at that laboratory
it's also been clear for some time that
there were many warning signs of the
dangers of the work the Chinese were
doing and the terrifyingly sloppy lab
practices they
utilized biological warfare threats are
real have been considered such for many
years collection on both state and
terrorist biowarfare programs is one of
cia's top priorities in fact it is
what's referred to as a tier zero
priority which means nothing takes
precedent
the existence of the lab from which Co
emerged was not a secret neither was the
fact that the Chinese were working
overtime to make Corona viruses more
dangerous to
humans and yet we received no
warning prior to the outbreak of the
pandemic when PE people began to get
sick here and around the world CIA could
apparently provide no useful information
regarding the origins of the
disease and even now years later CIA
seems unable to tell us precisely how
the pandemic
began that boils down to
this we had no sources inside China's
top Biol laab and we apparently have no
sources there
now so why
why is an organization that is staffed
with highly talented people and provided
with resources that quite frankly are
unparalleled anywhere else failing to
perform I'll give you two reasons and
then consider them in
succession
bureaucratization and
politicization let's begin with
bureaucratization OR what somebody much
cleverer than I has referred to as
bureaucratic hardening of the artery
gree CIA is in the business of
Espionage so we forget for a moment all
the gadgets and the technology and
everything that Hollywood can imagine
the core business of CIA is recruiting
spies inside Target organizations
handling them securely and producing
intelligence for policy makers in
Washington
DC at its heart this is a very old
business as they say the world's second
oldest
profession and its Essence has remained
unchanged for thousands of years this is
not a science it is an art there is a
reason Intelligence Officers talk in
terms of
tradecraft because it is a craft not
everybody can do it certainly not
everybody wants to do it because it can
be a very very hard
business a CIA case officer may be
called upon to do many things things in
the course of his or her career but when
it comes down to it his or her primary
job is this spotting assessing
developing and recruiting
spies that means getting close enough to
some often very objectionable people to
figure out what makes them tick
convincing them somehow to trust you
convincing them that you can keep them
alive and that they should help you by
betraying their colleagues their
countries their causes all things in
which they believe very
deeply that means getting a Russian
intelligence officer to take actions he
knows will result in his execution and
the disgrace of his family if he's
caught that means persuading an Iranian
nuclear scientist that working with you
will actually make his countryman safer
and help create a better future for all
Iranians that me convincing a member of
al-Qaeda that you are not the enemy of
Islam that you know your trade well
enough to keep him from ending up
suffering a very Grizzly fate if he is
discovered so what does that require
requires somebody with impeccable gut
instincts that can make decisions very
quickly on the Fly navigate through this
Maze of mirrors tolerate extremely high
degrees of ambiguity because you hardly
ever actually know anything for sure
when you are face to face with a
dangerous person in a slum in South Asia
or a desert in the Middle East you do
not have time to
deliberate and you sure can't call
Washington for advice because
Washington's filled with bureaucrats and
they have no idea what they're doing or
what you should
do we have forgotten all of
this we have done our level best to turn
CIA into just another Federal
agency recruiters no longer search for
intangibles or focus on key
psychological traits critical to success
in the world of
spying they look at
degrees existing levels of language
proficiency and increasingly at things
like the color of your skin and your
sexual
orientation training has become has been
softened and become increasingly
formbook in nature we act as if anybody
can be taught to conduct Espionage we
are now all fungible this is no longer
an Arcane craft to be practiced by a
select group of very unique people you
send somebody to training for a few
months they'll be
fine we have buried operations under
endless layers of middle
management the fact that we can move
large quantities of information over
vast distances somehow now compels us to
do so so a case officer in the field may
spend days writing up all the necessary
paperwork to document a single asset
meeting every moment they're doing that
is a moment they are not out meeting
sources they are not recruiting new
sources they are not learning the
environment around
them back home increasingly the ranks of
management are filled with individuals
who have never demonst rated that they
can accomplish anything on the street in
many cases they will have only left
Northern Virginia for a handful of short
trips
abroad they have laughed at the boss's
jokes they have demonstrated their falty
to the prevailing group think they have
moved paper attended meetings and
climbed the corporate
ladder in large
measure they have absolutely no idea how
to run an operation or recruit a
source